[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, we are Stephanie and Julia
from Rise the membership.
Rise the membership is a
program from Starr Health Co.
that helps female
college seniors
and recent graduates
to transition
into the professional world.
Rise provides an online
life skills school
with curated content
to equip its members
with necessary skills
and wellness tips
to support their transition.
By doing this, Rise attracts
young individual females,
organization with interest
in empowering female leaders,
as well as content
creators who wish
to establish their brands
by sharing impactful content
to Rise members.
With the help of
HILT $300 investment,
Rise has done some grounding
works part of the development
of its online platform.
Rise has conducted
over 30 interviews
with current and future
users, usability testing
to assess its beta platform,
and leveraged this insight
for the development of the full
version of the online platform.
Moving forward, Rise plans
to launch the full version
of the online platform
by January 2019,
shift its membership
to the new platform,
and open wider enrollment with
new $12 per month subscription.
Thank you for supporting Rise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]